good morning from the European
Parliament here in Strasbourg and thanks
for joining this live chat on YouTube
and on Facebook I'm Robert hucci from
the social media team uh Europeans have
seen their cost of living rise in the
past months as high gas electricity
prices have caused the spike in the
price of some goods and services uh and
the reopening of our economies following
the pandemic has driven inflation to
record highs Russia's war in Ukraine has
further deepened this crisis and has
slowed down is supposed to slow down the
economic growth in the EU which are the
sectors hit the most in the EU and how
our governments and the EU tackling this
crisis these are the questions that we
want to ask today and we'll hope to find
some answers to them so to discuss this
and parliament's efforts to tackle the
crisis on the crisis of cost of living
think in the EU on a European level I am
joined by two members of the parliament
leaders of two committees on my left I
have dragos bistlero chair of the
committee of the parliament responsible
for employment and social Affairs
welcome thank you and on my right I have
ludagnita Meyer who is the vice chair of
the committee on the economic and
monetary Affairs of the parliament
welcome
uh Mr Anita Meyer um
how has the EU been affected by this
crisis and by the rise in the
electricity and the energy crisis but
also uh by the double digit inflation
and how what sectors are particularly
affected so this is I guess what our
viewers would like to to know today so
first of all thanks for invitation and
this is uh important debate because uh
European people and businesses are badly
affected by current situation it
combines so many factors that are really
unique that it's not easy to say the one
that is the most important also not
possible to say that one sector is most
influenced but going back to a question
we should start with inflation because
inflation is very evil and that's why
it's really so important to get
inflation under control we should have
in mind that inflation has started a
relatively quick after let's say we we
started to get from the pandemics and
from lockdowns and surprisingly and this
is definitely good news the economy was
Stronger that was expected so we have
seen some inflation pressure we have
seen some demand pressure because the
firms were better off people were better
off at the same time maybe some of us
remember the disruption on supplies
there was a big ship that blocked the
Strategic route we have seen some some
fires in the factories developing the
microchips and so on so this was the
start of the inflation so we should not
forget that it started before the energy
prices that's why I mentioned that the
war in Ukraine has deepened this but the
real significantly deepen and then the
price of energies went up so quickly and
you know also we should not forget that
during the pandemics inflation the
energy costs drop down significantly
probably below kind of reasonable level
but then the increase was almost like 10
times so going back to the sectors
obviously those factories those
businesses that have high consumption of
energies will be sooner or later
affected obviously you can do something
about it the businesses that are less
dependent on external supplies for
example generate a lot of electricity on
their own they are better off the
businesses that locked in price for
let's say two years are less affected
but we should say that generally the
businesses that consume a lot of energy
or actually take the parts that they are
buying from other firms are also energy
intensive they are affected and then let
me go to second stage and this is why I
started inflation is evil inflation is
such a high
that the income of people the wages or
other income is just declining the real
income is declining so obviously people
have less money to spend so that means
in second stage also the businesses that
are sensitive to uh the demand ability
of people to maybe go to coffee and buy
expensive coffee maybe go for for a
little bit more expensive lunch a lot of
these families can see that they income
is declining they need to save more
money to have money to pay electricity
bills to buy the foods that is more
expensive they will be affected now so
that's why we we will probably see a
little bit of economic decline but
unfortunately this decline is almost
inevitable if you want to get inflation
under control so we should not forget
and this is last sentence I want to say
that obviously the government should
provide the support for businesses for
household but at the same time we should
have in mind that if support will be
strong enough inflation will stay high
and inflation is very evil we need to
get inflation down evil inflation and Mr
as Mr niedermeier mentioned wages uh uh
are staying the same in some countries
they are tackling the the some with some
sort of indexation but people are seeing
a big chunk of their income being eaten
up by by
um by uh Builds on electricity and high
food prices so uh what are some of the
immediate effects on on the use working
people
first of all what is important to
realize that why we'll talk that about a
bad hit on everyone in the union
we have a category that is mostly
affected or most affected by this
inflationary conditions and the bills
and I'm talking about the vulnerable
people so for the vulnerable people
right now the choice would be or it
already is in between paying the bills
or ensuring a proper meal for their
children
so what we are seeing right now is a
huge pressure on the have-nots of our
society of the ones that already were
really badly hit during the pandemic and
right now again they are suffering
because of this particular crisis and
here we are rediscovering topics that
they were there in the public space but
we are not that careful about them for
instance the concept of energy poverty
um we have been neglected that and and
somehow in in this quest for the green
transition we put together measures
related to the Bauhaus initiatives and
you know Energy Efficiency in buildings
and so on but now we realize how
important is to help the citizens you
know have a more efficient households
and and be able indeed to to even be
prosumers to produce their own
electricity if possible now coming back
to the effect on purchasing power indeed
um we see that the vulnerable people are
affected but we also see that categories
of uh you know medium income uh
population that have been started to to
to fall towards the vulnerability so
this is indeed an important social
crisis after all for that I believe that
we need to to take the proper measures
on one um on one hand to be sure that we
do have quite an active labor market
policy to be sure that people are not
losing their jobs especially in these
conditions and that we can indeed help
people with upskilling and re-skilling
to try to get better revenue for the
work that they are doing and not
nonetheless one important thing is to
use the European fund to cushion the
effect and then of course as I'm sure
that we have the opportunity to describe
to help them with micro Investments that
can diminish their bills to a program
such as repower for instance with power
can you uh build up a bit more and that
what is repower you I mean repower you
it's targeted right now both at smes and
households which is a new addition that
the European Parliament has has been uh
putting forward with a double Target on
one thing on one hand cutting Russians
uh dependency on gas and on the other
hand making Europe Greener more
efficient and diminishing the energy
bills for uh I I I'm going to repeat
that for for ordinary citizens and their
households and as well small
entrepreneurs smes so this is a very
important program is that EU label
program that will be uh felt uh starting
with I we we want to finish negotiation
in December starting with January we can
have this important in micro investment
schemes that can change the life for the
for the better for uh you know very many
citizens across Europe
National level do you see any
differences among EU countries in in
terms of inflation rates and and the way
governments are tackling it
the differences are really substantial
so we can say that in uh in eui and
Euros on average inflation is 10 percent
that doesn't tell you a lot because
there are countries that are around 20
percent they are kind of like the
balticans that are close to uh to five
percent and it's not easy to clearly see
the the the cost of such a big
differences uh because uh
weekends maybe see in the future that
inflation will get closer to each other
but let me point out just a few
potential reasons the first it's
possible that among the countries that
demand inflation that is not inflation
that is caused High by high energy
prices is different maybe some countries
emerge from from lockdowns and pandemics
with stronger economy some of them with
weaker combined with the fact that the
monetary policy the central banks were
not in in some some parts of Europe I
would say majority very quick to react
as demand inflation can kick off quicker
and cause that that the inflationary
start to accelerate then the second very
important reason different reaction by
the governments some governments took
the measures that seems to work somehow
like cut the the taxes on energies for
example
and these are the measures that work
some of them took measures that doesn't
seems to work so well so that means that
kind of temporary price on the on the
energies or even food food stock and
what has happened that it decelerate the
inflation but when the when the the
ceilings very moved there was a very
fast acceleration so you have many
factors that cause such a big
difference in inflation that make it
very difficult especially for ECB that
operates the monetary policy across
across the Eurozone to react
appropriately but now we can see with
the with the benefit of knowing what has
happened that the monetary policy should
have been a Tighter and we would not get
out of this rate dangerously High
inflation without using both the
monetary and the fiscal policy to fight
the inflation and it's really important
to get out of inflation to make sure
that our economy will get back to steady
and sustainable sustainable growth but
my best guess is that we can see a
little bit less of variation of
inflation into the future especially as
these short-term regulatory measures
like the ceilings of food or something
they'll fade away but I should also
mention that it is important how we here
in the European Union
manage the state aid rules because I
guess it's very important that we keep
the single Market as Fair as possible
and the situation where some member
states would use a very strong
supportive measures for the economy and
other states don't have enough money to
do that will cause not only differences
in inflation but also differences in the
in the fair market competition that was
going to be my question how how does
this impact the competition in the in
our market so first of all we should say
it's fully up to governments to decide
how to support the household and I'm
here fully in line with dragosh and I
guess most economists would say try to
be as targeted as possible have the
vulnerable swans I guess it's even time
to support the lower mid-income people
because they are suffering too but try
to avoid very very broad supportive
measures that are expensive for the
fiscal
and also has more potential to create to
create inflation so this is this is the
first so for for households it's up to
the governments there was a decision
also to to
allow the member states to to Grant the
kind of General support to smes that I
guess is pragmatic decision because
there are so many smes at the market
that's important that that we have so
many smes that administer support on
case-by-case basis would be maybe
economically wise but would not be the
feasible
and for big businesses we have that
temporary framework and I guess it's
important to to keep it because there
are countries and we both actually came
from the countries that don't have very
big fiscal space so the risk is if the
possibility for for member state to
support a special large businesses very
generously is not possible for countries
that don't have sufficient fiscal space
so this will create big Distortion uh on
the single market and obviously we are
in big trouble now with Avid the
countries across the globe that have
lower cost of the the energy like like
us but we should not forget that we need
to keep fair market competition across
the single Market because it's the
single Market that is the most important
economic mechanism that we have we have
in our hands and we must make sure that
single Market works as good as as it
could to make sure that the economy will
get back to sustainable sustainable
growth again how vulnerable are our
Industries and our working people uh in
such conditions I mean clearly this is a
tremendous hit that comes I mean we are
living in a in an era of multiple crisis
we've just exited or partially exited
the coveted one and enter multiple
crises as mentioned by ludac so so right
now the the issue is how can we provide
an exit out of out of this
regulatory measures of course very
important some sort of targeted support
for social situation and vulnerable
citizens very important but what is also
important is to to see how we can
resolve the demand problem as well so
not just I mean we do have a an issue
here that is very important so if we
will invest in this kind of Energy
Efficiency projects in helping
diminishing the bills and then
dependence on electricity
um this would mean that we we will be
able to do two things at the same time
on one hand to look at our ambition here
at the European level to push the green
transition to to be uh you know top-end
technologies that that would help us and
at the same time to have our citizens
less dependent on this kind of
volatility related to energy and and so
on so that's why I mentioned the power
EU because the energy bill is concerned
uh every one of us me you the European
institution each and every household and
Company in the EU and it's also a weapon
against Russia's blackmail on energy so
I think that this is quite important now
in terms of the smes very very quickly
and this one it's also very important to
create a safety net so that if we have
right now issues in terms of the
capacity available of energy we will be
able to put forward schemes such as the
ones using pandemic like sure you know
furlough schemes that will be able to
cushion
the the effects on on companies so that
if there will be temporary close Downs I
mean at least we will be able to react
immediately and have the necessary
resources but of course we hope that
this will not be the case but we always
need to be prepared and we have this
kind of tools at European level that
help tremendously the business sector
during the pandemic and these are as
part of the lessons learned that we can
use right now another important you law
backed by the European Parliament on
minimum wage is that on minimum wages
that should enforce collective
bargaining in the EU that means that
countries can enter uh workers trade
unions can enter into negotiations with
governments in many new countries this
exists already for example I live in
Belgium and I know for a fact that you
know many people can rely on the fact
that their wages will be indexated there
will be uh there will be some sort of of
the solution but this doesn't exist in
every country so how
how can we you how could this crisis
could describe the speed that the the
the the application of these New Year
rules because this is fairly new but it
takes time to absolutely I think that
the minimum wage is just one of the
measures that we are taking under the
European period of social rights and the
social agenda that we've developed over
the last years is right now really you
know proving its its positive effects on
especially the vulnerable part of the
population now on the minimum wage we
are very proud of the committee of
employment and social Affairs that we've
been able to finalize the negotiations
and let me just try to to give you an
angle that is not necessarily you know
discussed the minimum wage
directive is actually depoliticizing the
decision related to minimum wages
because it's actually empowering social
Partners to have this discussion and
providing the the mandatory the
obligation of for governments to to have
some sort of formulas or to take into
account become specific indicators in
adjusting you know and indexing minimum
wage some countries have are already
doing it automatically but what is
important right now and why this is
really a topical issue right now one of
the or actually the first indicator that
needs to be taken into account by by
member states with the minimum wage is
purchasing power so right now we have
exactly this issue where people have
lost purchasing power and if the minimum
wage directory would be applied that
means automatically the social Partners
will start discussing to see how the
purchasing power loss would actually be
reinstated there with indexation and
other schemes and I think that this is
this is really important for the
citizens of course our wish is to have
not necessarily more jobs in Europe but
better jobs in Europe so that we are not
going to have uh too many people we pay
that minimum wage but I would say that
this is a very important file an
instrument to Depot all these size
decisions and give the people a chance
to to to to exit you know the inner work
at work poverty and situations where we
we can see them right now thank you
um High inflation is here to stay is
that uh a fair assessment uh
I would say in my view more correct
assessment is that it will take time
before we get out from high inflation uh
but we really should not extend this
period for longer than necessary
obviously the work of the Central Bank
and I'm speaking a little bit like a
former Central Banker now is very
delicate because it's not only getting
from very high inflation maybe even to
negative inflation it's about the
landing at the zone of low inflation
this is very delicate the job and this
would be the how to reduce the cost of
this inflation so really the target
would be to gradually get gradually but
clearly get inflation down to the Zone
when it used to be so let's say let's
say between one and three percent I hope
the central banks now really have a more
clear picture how serious the situation
is so they must really focus on the main
goal that is clearly defined in the law
so that means fight with fight with
inflation as I point out at the
beginning
I guess that current situation when we
unfortunately experience decline of real
income and dragosh is very correct in
saying that this is unfortunately
affecting those most vulnerable that's
why the governments have to pay
attention to them
it is the this forms the circumstances
when inflation will go graduate down but
also providing that governments will not
do too much of fiscal expansion we have
seen yesterday commissioner dombrovsky
stressing that the fiscal policy cannot
be so-called expansionary it should be
neutral because otherwise we will be
stuck with inflation above 5-10 percent
and this will not make any good to
anyone and especially for for poor
people because they are affected the
most so I guess we are on the right
track the situation is incredibly
complicating it combines many factors
that are not in our favor but we should
not forget also about some positive news
so first of all
economy emerge from the from the
pandemics and lockdowns stronger than we
expected and this is a good thing the
second what obviously something that I
highly appreciate it's not so much
economical but political we were able to
find such an incredible unity in
reaction to Russia aggression to Ukraine
that is very important I guess we have
never been so close together in Europe
and also we sell our transatlantic
partner us and basically all Western
democracies that is fantastic and I
guess what is amazing achievement how so
far we are handling the energy crisis in
March if you would ask anyone here
if he can handle without Russian gas the
reply would be no because we were 40
depending on the gas now the Russian gas
is almost gone and we know that we will
handle obviously we must keep pushing
the savings that is incredibly important
we need to push more for something
dragosh was talking about more
Renewables More Energy Efficiency but it
seems that we are handling it's not over
it will still be it will take years
probably it will take yours probably it
will take years but we are on the right
track we just cannot slow down we must
keep and this is fantastic achievement
also we work together I talk about about
the state aid about trying to keep the
single Market together I guess we both
would agree that this is absolutely
essential so situation is difficult to
get out of that really high inflation
that is very dangerous is not free of
charge but I guess there is quite a good
chance that we will handle if we keep
together Evie Kim competent EV keep
focused there is a cost to this and to
to Russia's war in Ukraine and we've
seen a lot of solidarity as Mr Nita
Meyer mentioned will we see this
solidarity and this Unity uh still
um be strong in the EU I think that this
is the best place to talk about in the
European Parliament we've been acting
swiftly and you know been the pioneers
of solidarity and cohesion uh in these
difficult years in in this mandate and I
I believe that the main difference that
citizens can see in terms of the
reaction of the institutions is that
while the previous financial crisis was
about austerity and about you know
buckling up and trying to figure out at
National level what are the solutions
right now the rule is that we are coming
to the common response the recovery
resilience plans are right right now
starting to to kick in and have their
role repower is just going directly
targeting citizens and then you have of
all the other measures that are going to
come up with investments in increasing
energy Supply reducing demand and this
would be the way in which Europe is
reacting you know that's the beauty of
the European Union's strength when it
comes in times of you know testing uh
its the values that we're having and
also the policies and I would just like
to say that EU policy shouldn't be about
you know spreading helicopter money and
you know populist promises or
nationalist things that we need to to go
back to our turf this is about you know
relying on the citizens capacity to to
act together and and to to emerge
stronger out of each and every crisis
and I would say that these longer term
Solutions and their opportunities and
reforms that and Investments that we are
putting forward are going to take us out
of the inflation crisis as well thank
you very much for ending on a slightly
positive note and it's important that
our viewers also get an idea of what is
going on and how the parliaments and the
European Union is a tackling the cost of
living crisis and thank you to everyone
who followed this uh live chat I hope to
see you soon
thank you